PROFESSOR: If you're
a teacher and you're
inventing a course for the first
time, or revising it a lot,
you sit down with
your teaching partners
and you put on the
table all the ideas.
Teaching, you've got an
ever-expanding universe
of knowledge out
there, and you have
to cherry-pick the things that
are going to be important.
It has to hang together.
One of the strategies
JoAnne and I thought,
when we went into the current
iteration of teaching 5.07
biological chemistry, was
to abandon completely,
higher eukaryotes, namely
us, because genome sequencing
projects had sequenced so many
bacteria that one could create
an entire course in biochemistry
that would be very meaningful,
just focusing on microorganisms.
We spent a couple of days
reading and thinking about it.
That would be the course
JoAnne and I would teach,
if it weren't for the
fact that we actually
have-- feel as though we have
a commitment to students that
are going to go on
to medical school
and therefore, if we avoided
mammalian biochemistry,
students wouldn't know
anything about the mitochondria
and organelles, and
things like that that
are associated with eukaryotes.
We wouldn't be able to make
these connections to disease,
the physiological scenarios.
Nevertheless, why were we
so interested in bacteria?
What would be an
interesting story,
that I might be able to tell
you, if we had taken that path.
So we have a fellow in
biological engineering,
named Eric Alm.
And he is an informaticist
and an engineer,
and an extremely good chemist.
He really knows his pathways.
When he looks at
a cell, he thinks
about what it is, but
also where it came from,
in terms of how it evolved from
precursors, its family tree,
so to speak.
One of the most
interesting organisms
that he's published
on, not too long ago,
is an organism
called, Desulforudis.
And this would be a wonderful
biochemistry course in itself.
He wondered, if he went out and
dug up a cubic meter of dirt--
and outside MIT-- and if
he did 16S RNA sequencing,
how many living things would
be there, many thousands, maybe
10,000.
Then he asked the question, what
if you went down 100 meters,
you know, maybe you see 1,000.
But what if you go down
until there's really
only one thing there.
And that's what he did, going
down two miles into the ground.
And there was a single, species
ecosystem called, Desulforudis.
And I remember
seeing this paper,
and I brought it over to JoAnne.
I was so excited
because the last picture
showed its metabolic network,
its metabolic pathways.
It had everything.
And it makes sense.
It can't rely on other things.
For example, we can't make
all of our amino acids.
We got to get them
from food that we eat,
or in our co-factors,
some of our vitamins
are made by the
bacteria in our gut.
So, if all the bacteria
disappear, we would too.
So we rely on other
things, but Desulforudis
doesn't rely on anything.
So when you look at it's
biochemical networks,
what you see is that
it can fix nitrogen. It
can take N2 and convert
it NH3, and then
put that into amino
acids, and it can
make all of its amino acids.
It has a really good
pentose phosphate pathway.
It actually uses
radiation in a strange way
to generate some of the
energy that it needs.
It uses it to generate
carbon monoxide.
Ultimately, that CO is going
to form an acetyl group that
will be able to generate
all of the organic material
inside the Desulforudis.
It's got all kinds of
electron transport pathways.
So it's developed
enormous versatility
by being a
single-species ecosystem.
So, again, this
was a course where
we had to make a compromise
because of our clientele.
Teachers have to
think about that.
We have to teach to what
the people need in order
to go on to the next step.
But as sort of a
closing thought,
I think that it
would be wonderful
for next-generation biochemists
to really turn their attention
to the microbial world, to
teach this vast biochemistry
and understand how
bacteria effortlessly,
swap biochemical pathways,
pick-up entire biochemical
pathways without even
breaking a sweat.
Whenever they find
themselves stressed,
they just pick up a new
pathway and they survive.